where are all the [ __ ] it's like
they see the GoPro and they get on their
best behavior these videos are now gonna
be called smooth sailing all right this
thing's gonna be talking a whole time
whatever we could leave a run all
improvised with it hey what's going on
it's bill burr and I'm talking over the
robot lady on the map here and it's time
for another one of my instructional
driving videos here on the all things
comedy network for those you unfamiliar
with these videos I have a tendency to
lose my [ __ ] and evidently according to
people who think that they're therapists
they tell me it's because I have
expectations of people what are you
doing what are you doing are you coming
over are you coming over go you [ __ ]
[ __ ] nice smoke though that wasn't bad
everybody's doing everything correctly
out here it's just like perfect Thursday
and I make another light
this is [ __ ] great I feel like I'm in
the presidential Caravan right now a
couple of Secret Service guys you know
hanging on to the side with their
[ __ ] running board and they handle
it's just like perfect Thursday and I
make another light I don't know what
this street is but this is my mode this
is my most favorite [ __ ] Street in
Los Angeles I've literally not hit a
[ __ ] red light there's nothing
funnier than a red light okay then you
step on the gas you blow through the
light you make sure the guy behind you
makes it he didn't is he's lollygagging
I'm thinking about MC I'm having empathy
for other people here's another green
light please turn left in 500 feet now
how can I turn left here it says no left
turn look at the same once they make an
illegal turn here oh I guess I can't
make a u-turn can I do it right here
we're gonna find out alright now what I
just did there you're not supposed to do
that unless you look both ways and you
don't see a cop
jesus [ __ ] christ this is the rig
dude I feel like I'm on adam-12 it's
like the population of LA in the 1960s I
feel like like a plague hit LA and like
everybody died right as we were putting
these [ __ ] cameras up look at this
I'm pretty just behaving themselves
staying in the correct lanes I don't
think we need to make any more of these
videos I think everybody's driving great
now I didn't realize it was desolate
areas of Greater Los Angeles I feel like
we found it alright I just made a right
now left lane it's at a COI wait am I
the problem I think I'm the problem
oh my goodness look at dude there's
literally nobody on the [ __ ] Road
this is [ __ ] hilarious
I've never had this driving experience
ever in LA this is like a feel-good
movie today listen everything worked out
did I just [ __ ] that up I think I did
I'm in the wrong goddamn Lane all right
now I'm going to show you something
you're not supposed to do this is called
the glide you sort of sashay over this
is gonna be a [ __ ] Boston move right
here and here we go and you can't get
mad when somebody beeps at you when you
do this what you do we should just kind
of you just can't huh you just kind of
do this like a I'm just sort of
mirroring your movements he didn't beep
at me all right you see that kept a
little distance
there's only arrows they're pointing
which way I was supposed to be going I'm
the worst
well I don't think we learned a lot
today other than what not to do the way
I was driving people I don't pretend to
know things and shouldn't you be at work
right now instead of sitting in your
cubicle secretly watching these things
I don't even know what I did I just
literally went for like one of the most
pleasurable [ __ ] drives I've ever
gone in LA that was like a country road
and I'm gonna take credit for that I
think everybody's listening I think I'm
changing lives with these videos all
right well thank you for watching I hope
it was educational I hope it was
entertaining have a nice day and God
bless the United States of America
[Music]